presenter: I wanted to welcome
everyone to this event.
I actually worked at Warner Music Group
and Eric was one of the artists that
was signed with Warner Brother Records
which was one of our business units,
and I had the pleasure of hearing him
play about two and a half years ago,
and it was probably the most
memorable event of my life
when it comes to music.
And I'm super excited to have him
come here and perform for you all.
His album was released
in August of 2007
and one of his best friends actually
ended up emailing Perez Hilton
who posted Eric's MySpace page
on his site
and then it was a success overnight.
So we're super, super excited
to have him here
and I hope you guys enjoy the show.
Thanks.
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
How's everybody doin'?
male #1: Good.
Eric Hutchinson: Great.
[chord on keyboard]
Thanks for comin' out.
Appreciate you guys
gettin' dressed up.
[intro on keyboard]
♪ Oh, ♪
♪ Oh, Oh, Oh ♪
♪ I got arrested in the dark
of the night ♪
♪ the cop got restless
as he read me my rights ♪
♪ he told me "I'm always envious
of those that I jail ♪
♪ if I got locked up nobody'd
come to help me post bail" ♪
♪ and I said "oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ went to a party on the side of a hill ♪
♪ met three Latinas
who had gotten their fill ♪
♪ they told me "nobody ever
gets us down on our knees ♪
♪ simply to help us take
a load off our feet." ♪
♪ and I said "oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ and I'm never sure
what I'm living for ♪
♪ but it's always on my mind ♪
♪ someone comes along
always proves me wrong ♪
♪ think I'm gonna be fine ♪
♪ And I picked a pocket
just to give it all back ♪
♪ took out the license
left the money in tact ♪
♪ the man said :I wanna thank you"
and I had to ask why ♪
♪ "That was the old me I was living a lie" ♪
♪ and I said "oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ and I said, "oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ riding the subway with
the scent of her hair ♪
♪ she took out a toothbrush
started using it there ♪
she explained "I'm always sure
today's the day I will die
♪ I wanna look good if I get
to look God in the eye" ♪
♪ and I said "oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ and I'm never sure ♪
♪ what I'm living for ♪
♪ but it's always on my mind ♪
♪ someone comes along
always proves me wrong ♪
♪ think I'm gonna be fine ♪
♪ We get lost in the back
of our minds ♪
♪ got nothing to burn
but time, time, time ♪
♪ everybody's got the love ♪
♪ but they keep it inside ♪
♪ We get lost in the back
of our minds ♪
♪ got nothing to burn
but time, time, time ♪
♪ everybody's got the love
they keep it inside ♪
♪ Wow, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Met an acquaintance
we were reintroduced ♪
♪ with more in common than
we had in our youth ♪
♪ she told me "you look the same"
I said "I'm now a new man" ♪
♪ she asked me "how does that change"
"I started giving a damn" ♪
♪ and I said "oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ I said now "oh, oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ I said now "oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh oh, oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ I said now "oh, oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪
♪ I said now "oh, oh, oh, oh, oh" ♪♪
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you guys.
I don't actually know if
anybody introduced me.
My name is Eric Hutchinson
and thank you guys
for comin' out.
I didn't hear it I was outside
so I as I was playing
the song I was like,
"I don't know if I just walked in
and started playing -- [laughter]
like a total jerk."
So anyway let me
introduce myself at least.
My name's Eric Hutchinson,
appreciate you coming.
If you need to leave I'm gonna
take it personally.
[intro on keyboard]
So I'm playing,
I'm working on my new
album right now.
I'm gonna play a few
new songs for you guys.
Thank you.
And --
this is one of them.
[intro on keyboard]
It's called "Best Days."
♪ I get myself up every day ♪
♪ To fight this woe
is me demeanor ♪
♪ If things had gone another way ♪
♪ Now would my grass
be any greener? ♪
♪ And as I'm struggling on my own ♪
♪ I wonder if I'm not alone ♪
♪ Give and take, ♪
♪ we catch our breaks ♪
♪ We all learn to survive ♪
♪ But don't look now ♪
♪ I said don't look now ♪
♪ Cause here we are, ♪
♪ living the best days of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ And I fly around the world to spend ♪
♪ My nights with strangers
and their lovers ♪
♪ I notice happiness depends ♪
♪ On if we share it with each other ♪
♪ So is there somethin' I can do ♪
♪ To make my way back home to you ♪
♪ Give and take, ♪
♪ we catch our breaks ♪
♪ We all learn to survive ♪
♪ But don't look now ♪
♪ I said don't look now ♪
♪ Cause here we are, ♪
♪ living the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ And as we're walkin'
through the fire ♪
♪ Isn't it great to be alive? ♪
♪ Give and take, ♪
♪ we catch our breaks ♪
♪ We all learn to survive ♪
♪ Oh, but don't look now ♪
♪ I said don't look now ♪
♪ Cause here we are, ♪
♪ Living the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the best days
of our lives ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ These are the best days
of our lives ♪♪
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thanks.
I'm not tellin' ya how to do your job,
but in the future if we could
keep the applause going
'til I'm over to this station --
[laughter]
with the guitar --
[applause and cheering]
I appreciate that but I'm
already over here so --
[laughter]
don't need to be clapping now.
So
this is my first time at Google.
Pretty excited.
Not yours,
you're not as excited so --
but I appreciate
you havin' me today.
[guitar intro]
This is a song I wrote
all about Google.
Not actually true.
[guitar intro]
This song's called
"All Over Now."
♪ Call me crazy if you've
got it in you ♪
♪ But these people don't seem to mind ♪
♪ Sweet vermouth ain't
telling me the truth ♪
♪ A little stubbornness
will work out fine ♪
♪ A bottom feeder at
the end of my rope
♪ But I'm wondering
where this rope began ♪
♪ Gonna circle around what
I couldn't help bring down ♪
♪ It's just supply with demand ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ Nothing looks the same, ♪
♪ ohh ♪
♪ Even when there's been
no change, ♪
♪ ohh ♪
♪ Say that something's
gonna give ♪
♪ And it's all giving out on you ♪
♪ When it's all over now ♪
♪ It's all over now ♪
♪ It's no longer fun
and it's often overdone ♪
♪ So it's all over now ♪
♪ A large pickup truck
with a little cargo towed ♪
♪ Gets from baker's
to the laundromat ♪
♪ These daily fights all
start to sound alike ♪
♪ I guess I'm gonna
have to live with that ♪
♪ Short changed ♪
♪ Now it's gettin' even harder
to identify the repetition ♪
♪ Short changed ♪
♪ Now it's gettin' even harder
to identify the repetition ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ Will I simply peel away, ohh ♪
♪ It seems more likely everyday, ohh ♪
♪ Say that something's gonna give ♪
♪ And it's all giving out on you ♪
♪ When it's all over now ♪
♪ It's all over now ♪
♪ It's no longer fun
and it's often overdone ♪
♪ So it's all over now ♪
♪ And if you came here to tell me
that you're sorry for the pain ♪
♪ you couldn't cause ♪
♪ Then save your breath and use it
just to regain what you have lost, ♪
♪ ohh ♪
♪ And look at the cost ♪
♪ It's all over now ♪
♪ And it's all over now ♪
♪ It's no longer fun and
it's often overdone ♪
♪ So it's all over now ♪
♪ It's all over now ♪
♪ It's not longer fun and
it's all been overdone ♪
♪ So it is all over now ♪
♪ It's all over now ♪
It's all over now ♪
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
You guys havin' a good time so far?
You can be honest.
Good, good,
me too.
It feels good here.
So I felt bad about lying about
the last song being about Google.
male #2: [inaudible]
Eric Hutchinson: Sorry?
Eric Hutchinson: Can we do that here?
[laughter]
I don't exactly know
what the parameters are
but I'm definitely worried about
not being Google-able
if anything goes wrong.
Does that sort of thing happen?
Is it like the Net with
Sandra Bullock where --
if I show up tomorrow
I've been wiped off --
[laughter]
existence?
Not a lot of Net fans here?
[laughter]
'Cause you didn't watch
TBS in like 2001.
[laughs]
[guitar intro]
So this is a Google song
I just wrote
while I was singin' that last
song to make up for it.
It's sort of a John Denver vibe.
[guitar intro]
♪ I have to wonder what it's
like to say you work at Google ♪
♪ When you're at a family party
or a cocktail affair ♪
♪ Must be annoying
I would assume ♪
♪ 'cause then you have to stand and
listen to all the same annoying questions ♪
♪ That's what I assume. ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm just thinkin'
if I was at a party ♪
♪ and I met someone
who worked at Google ♪
♪ I would have about
a hundred questions ♪
♪ and I'd ask and make
an ass of myself. ♪
[laughter]
♪ So is it true that
when you go out ♪
♪ or when you're home back
with your family ♪
♪ you try not to talk about it ♪
♪ When I'm on a plane
and some asks what I do ♪
♪ I tell 'em I work in computers ♪
♪ Just pays the bills
and that usually shuts it down ♪
[laughter]
♪ But if you're on a plane and
you say you work for Google ♪
♪ that's a problem ♪
♪ Now it's four and a half hours
back to D.C. ♪
♪ That you're gonna
have to talk about it ♪
[laughter]
♪ But I also wonder
if you're at a party ♪
♪ when you say you work at Google ♪
♪ do you get to skip to the head
of the line for the drinks? ♪
[laughter]
♪ Are you intimating? ♪
♪ Are you scary? ♪
♪ I don't know what else to think ♪
[laughter]
♪ So I wonder what it's like
to say you work at Google ♪
♪ To say that you control
my very Gmail account ♪
♪ Hutchinson at Gmail.com ♪♪
[laughter]
That's it.
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
That's unexpected,
thank you.
[intro on keyboard]
This is a song I wrote about
those people in your life
that you're supposed
to be closer with
and for whatever reason
you just can't get there.
Do you have those
people in your life?
[intro on keyboard]
Are they sitting next to you?
[laughter]
Just give me a small wink.
This song's called
"The People I Know."
♪ I've got a best friend
who I've known some time ♪
♪ And after all of these years
I've try to read his mind ♪
♪ And when he leaves the room
I can feel him sigh ♪
♪ As his thoughts they slip out
like whispers ♪
♪ Who would've know
it'd be this hard to wait ♪
♪ For one person to person
to communicate ♪
♪ And it never feels dramatic
but we complicate ♪
♪ Thank God for old friends
they always forgive us ♪
♪ I'm longing for the days
I am not so tense ♪
♪ And friends are only that ♪
♪ And everything makes sense ♪
♪ If I am not myself then
who am I pretendin' to be? ♪
♪ And I said how am I gonna get by ♪
♪ Without the help
of the people I know ♪
♪ For better or worse
we all come together ♪
♪ And they won't let me die alone ♪
♪ I said they won't let me die alone ♪
♪ And I've got a sister
who I barely see ♪
♪ Despite the fact that she lives
right up the block from me ♪
♪ And when we run into
each other on the street ♪
♪ It's like two strangers
soul to soul ♪
♪ When I was younger
she was younger too ♪
♪ It seems the space is the only
thing that really grew ♪
♪ And now we're both grown up
and still without a clue ♪
♪ Thank God for family
they always forgive us ♪
♪ I'm thinking of the house
I was always raised ♪
♪ In every family tree
some history remains ♪
♪ If I am not myself, ♪
♪ then who am I pretendin' to be ♪
♪ And I said how am I gonna get by ♪
♪ Without the help
of the people I know ♪
♪ For better or worse
we all come together ♪
♪ And they won't let me die alone ♪
♪ I said they won't let me die alone ♪
♪ Maybe I'm not supposed
to be close ♪
♪ And I said how am I gonna get by ♪
♪ Without the help
of the people I know ♪
♪ For better or worse
we all come together ♪
♪ And they won't let me die alone ♪
♪ I-I-I said now
how am I gonna get by ♪
♪ When I'm afraid of
the people I know ♪
♪ For better or worse
we all come together ♪
♪ And they won't let me die alone ♪
♪ I said they won't let me die alone ♪
[applause and cheering]
[intro on keyboard]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
This song's called
"Food Chain."
If you can do me a favor just
for the rest of the show on here
even if you've never heard this song
before or even if you hate it,
if you can still just cheer,
just give me a little bit
of fake feedback here
after I sing the song titles.
This song's called "
Food Chain. "
[cheering]
♪ Don't let this affect the game ♪
♪ every five months
we act the same ♪
♪ I never get used
to putting you off ♪
♪ And no one could'vez scripted this ♪
♪ who knows what'll come of it ♪
♪ I refuse to believe ♪
♪ it was all just a waste ♪
♪ So look around everybody's
on the food chain funny ♪
♪ but from day to day
we get from bottom to top ♪
♪ and if you get lost
you start over again ♪
♪ but we don't ever get to know ♪
♪ we don't ever get to stop ♪
♪ [keyboard playing]
♪ I wake up in this oblivious state ♪
♪ Go to sleep trying
to save some face ♪
♪ 'cause I've never been one
for acting naive ♪
♪ [keyboard playing]
♪ And so what we've got
nothing to prove ♪
♪ Why on earth would
we soften the mood? ♪
♪ Do we think that this wire
is better left live? ♪
S♪ o look around everybody's
on the food chain funny ♪
♪ but from day to day we get
from bottom to top ♪
♪ and if you get lost
you start over again ♪
♪ but we don't ever get to, ♪
♪ no we don't ever get to stop ♪
♪ I would've known better
if I was on the outside ♪
♪ [keyboard playing]
♪ I would've known better
if I was on the outside ♪
♪ looking in looking in ♪
♪ but this chain just eats away
at the people who use it ♪
♪ and no ones gonna say ♪
♪ that it's easier losin' touch
with who we need ♪
♪ but we're lonelier on the outside ♪
♪ [keyboard playing]
♪ Everybody's on the food
chain funny ♪
♪ but from day to day
we get from bottom to top ♪
♪ and if you get lost
start over again ♪
♪ but we don't ever get to ♪
♪ no we don't ever get to ♪
♪ we don't ever get to ♪
♪ Don't ever get to stop ♪
♪[keyboard playing]
♪ Don't ever get to stop ♪♪
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you.
And good work.
I can see why you're all here.
I mean you bond together
as a team immediately.
I love that.
♪ [guitar intro]
This is another new song.
It's about telling the people
you love that you love them.
It's called " The Same thing."
♪ [guitar intro]
♪ The tip of your tongue holds
the thoughts that we all think ♪
♪ Voices from beyond
the brink of humanity ♪
♪ It is you is it me? ♪
♪ we're both right ♪
♪ we're all thinkin'
the same thing ♪
♪ Life's most basic truths ♪
♪ are the ones that we don't share ♪
♪ keep 'em hangin' in thin air ♪
♪ leavin' us to guess ♪
♪ Who else is in this mess? ♪
♪ Well let it out ♪
♪ We're all thinkin' the same thing ♪
♪ We're thinkin' nobody
will hear our voice ♪
♪ or that we never even got a choice ♪
♪ ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Sayin' I love you feels
just like it should ♪
♪ So who would you love
if you knew that you could? ♪
♪ Time changes your mind ♪
♪ and there's nothin' you can do ♪
♪ Set yourself free with the truth ♪
♪ Hand in hand ♪
♪ We universally understand
and let it out ♪
♪ We're all thinkin' the same thing ♪
♪ We're thinkin' nobody
will hear our voice ♪
♪ or that we never even got a choice ♪
♪ ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Sayin' I love you feels
just like it should ♪
♪ So who would you love
if you knew that you could? ♪
♪ I'm drownin' inside gonna
set my soul on fire ♪
♪ But you can quench my last desire ♪
♪ Heart to heart ♪
♪ We all knew it from the start ♪
♪ So let it out ♪
♪ We're all thinkin' the same thing ♪
[applause]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
[keyboard intro]
Got a few more here
so if you've been holdin' back
a little somethin'
you know in the tank
saving it for towards the end
of the show now
would be a good time
to not hold back anymore.
[keyboard intro]
This song's called
"Okay, It's Alright With Me."
[applause and cheering]
This is perfect.
Now I can never know --
if you like the song. [laughter]
I like to presume that you do.
♪ Ok it's alright with me ♪
♪ some things are just meant to be ♪
♪ it never comes easily ♪
♪ and when it does
I'm already gone ♪
♪ I'm practically never still ♪
♪ more likely to move until ♪
♪ I end up alone at will ♪
♪ my life continues inchin' along ♪
♪ When Bernadette comes ♪
♪ I get lost on her time ♪
♪ She's much too sweet and
she's always gonna be ♪
♪ When I return to her arms
and her eyes ♪
♪ it might not be the same ♪
♪ but it's alright with me ♪
♪ Ok it's alright with me ♪
♪ some people are scared to see ♪
♪ what's happening frequently ♪
♪ but I would never shy from a fight ♪
♪ Heartbeat with a high demand ♪
♪ often will go hand in hand ♪
♪ but I'm sick of just starting plans ♪
♪ I wanna spend the rest of my life. ♪
♪ When Bernadette comes ♪
♪ I get lost on her time ♪
♪ She's much too sweet and
she's always gonna be ♪
♪ When I return to her arms
and her eyes ♪
♪ it might not be the same ♪
♪ but it's alright with me ♪
♪ It's alright with me ♪
♪ Okay, it's alright with me ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, ♪
♪ it's alright with me ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Ok, it is alright with me ♪
♪ Ok, it's alright with me ♪
♪ Some things are just meant to be ♪
♪ It never comes easily ♪
♪ But when it does I'm already gone ♪♪
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thank you.
Great water here at Google.
[laughter]
I went for the room
temperature instead of cold --
it's a nice distinction
at the cafeteria, very nice.
Most places just have boiling hot
which is always hard for lunch.
If you're interested I do Bar Mitzvah's,
I do a full hour
of just water jokes.
[laughter]
So I have one more song here
and then I guess we're maybe
doing a Q & A
which is shorthand in the music
industry for question and answer.
So if you think you
might have a question
this might be the time to start
thinking about what that might be
because you know oftentimes
I've seen Q & A's before
and I've watched some of the ones
that have been happening here
and it's usually that awkward
like five minutes
where people are just flabbergasted
by asking questions.
So I know I've been giving a lot of
constructive criticism today but --
it's just more of a suggestion.
If you wanna think of some
questions I totally give you a,
I give you the right to totally
blank out during this last song.
Alright.
This song's called
"Rock and Roll."
[cheering]
[guitar intro]
♪ He's been waiting around
for the weekend ♪
♪ Figuring which club to sneak in ♪
♪ Fancy drinks and fifty-dollar
cover charge ♪
♪ Lately it's been a big hassle
Heineken and Newcastle ♪
♪ To make sure he's fitting in
and living large ♪
♪ Disregard the lies that he will tell
and what he's probably like ♪
♪ 'cause It's not hard his charm is
gonna get him through the night ♪
♪ 'Cause if he wanna to rock he rocks ♪
♪ If he wanna to roll he rolls ♪
♪ He can roll with the punches ♪
♪ Long as he feels like
he's in control ♪
♪ Na, na, na, na, na, na, na ♪
♪ See her heavy makeup
and cut t-shirt ♪
♪ Every girl out wants to be her ♪
♪ But they look the same already
why adjust ♪
♪ Reading the magazine secrets ♪
♪ Forgettin' the topical regrets ♪
♪ If she comes home all alone
the nights a bust ♪
♪ It's a must the swivel in her hips ♪
♪ And the look she gives It's all her trust
if only in the morning ♪
♪ She knew where she lived ♪
♪ 'Cause if she wanna to rock she rocks ♪
♪ If she wanna roll she rolls ♪
♪ She can roll with the punches ♪
♪ Long as she feels like she's in control
If she wanna stay she stays ♪
♪ If she wanna go she goes ♪
♪ She doesn't care
how she gets there ♪
♪ Long as she gets somewhere
she knows oh no ♪
♪ ah na na na na na na na na ♪
♪ And in a wink on the brink ♪
♪ From drink to drink and at the bar ♪
♪ With cash to blow ♪
♪ Shot to shot it's getting' hot ♪
♪ Advance the plot to see how far ♪
♪ It's gonna go ♪
♪ All depends so ditch the friends ♪
♪ And grab a cab ♪
♪ Another chance at cheap romance ♪
♪ Doesn't count 'cause the room
is spinning ♪
♪ Nothing to lose tonight
they both are winning ♪
♪ And they fall in love
as they fall in bed ♪
♪ They sing If they wanna rock
they rock ♪
♪ If they wanna roll they roll ♪
♪ They can roll with the punches ♪
♪ Long as they feel like
they're in control ♪
♪ If they wanna stay they stay ♪
♪ If they wanna go they go ♪
♪ They don't care
how they get there ♪
♪ Long as they get somewhere
they know oh no ♪
♪ ah na na na ... ♪
♪ ah na na na ... ♪♪
[applause and cheering]
Eric Hutchinson: Thanks a lot guys.
male #3: First off I think I hate you
for your obvious facility
with music and lyrics.
So thank you.
Eric Hutchinson: You guys
are intense here at Google.
[laughter] Is this
how everything starts?
Is this how everything starts?
male #3: No.
Eric Hutchinson: Okay.
male #3: But thank you
very much for the show,
it was a lot of fun.
Eric Hutchinson: I can't tell if people
are comin' to the microphone
or leaving they're al--
male #3: Sorry.
[laughter]
Eric Hutchinson: Everyone's doin'
that I'm tryin'-- [laughter]
male #3: Yeah, exactly.
We have too many meetings
around here that's the problem.
So when I grew up I bought CDs
and albums
and I discovered music
at the record store
and now obviously with your music
I discovered it on iTunes.
So how do you feel about how people
are sort of stumbling upon your music
and not having something physical
in their hand for the most part?
Do you think that affects the way
we like hear your music
and interpret what you've given?
Eric Hutchinson: Yeah,
I think,
well I have two feelings on it:
I think iTunes has been absolutely,
I mean the Internet in general
everything's been amazing for finding out,
I mean I hear more music
than I ever heard before
and I think a lot of people
are that same way.
The only thing that I really miss
and I still actually have CDs
and some people are better
with LPs or records of whatever,
but I dismissed,
we're seeing the end of the album
sort of where people,
even when you buy an album you usually
put it on shuffle or whatever or,
it's thrown into your sort of
world of music that you have
and I do the same thing a lot of times.
But I think where you separate
the men from the boys with artists
is who can make a full album
of material not just one song,
who can do a full album's
worth of interesting,
who can keep my attention,
these days if you can keep
my attention for 45 minutes
that's pretty impressive to me.
So I just think we're missing,
and it doesn't matter anymore people,
I have friends with kids
that will never, ever miss
having a CD or anything
'cause they don't even understand
what that means.
Now it's just all about I get music
and then I put it onto this thing
and I listen to it
whenever I feel like it.
So --
male #4: I'm of the previous generation.
I was actually just goin' through
my old 45s recently,
but I don't know much
of your background.
A month or two ago
I was driving north on 101
and I heard this awesome song
and I pulled out my phone
and hit Shazam and said,
"Okay, "
I bought Rock and Roll on iTunes
and bam 30 seconds later there it was.
Eric Hutchinson: Yeah,
I mean to me Shazam is,
like that's the example
of what music is now
where you hear something
and 20 seconds later you own it.
I mean it's pretty amazing.
male #4: So by way of background
at what point did you,
so I don't know
whether this is your day job
or if there's something else that
you do when you're not saying,
"Okay now I'm a musician,
now I'm gonna put an album out
and be on the radio."
Do you have a,
is there a seamless blend there
or is this --
Eric Hutchinson: Well this
is the day job as well.
Tonight I work at In and Out --
[laughter] Burger.
[laughs] Now yeah it's
full time and that's true.
But for me lately I'm working
a lot from beats.
I usually start with a beat
and then kind of see what that
leads me to play on top of it
and I usually will sort of sing words,
whatever comes into my brain,
and then I'll sort of get into a paper
and arrange it and see what --
I'm kind of big into sort of letting
the subconscious sort of lead
and sometimes you'll write a song
and then a year later
I'll look back and be like,
"Wow that's exactly
what's going on with me.
I didn't even realize I was
writing a song about that."
So for me it's definitely
melody first and then try,
a lot of times I'm definitely on
the lookout always for things
to write about,
songs to,
what I wanna say.
Especially these days I mean I'll probably
have 10 songs on my album,
I wanna make sure each
song has something to say,
what's the point
of listening to it?
male #5: Hi.
So when I told people
that you were coming
my Dad told me that you also
grew up in Takoma Park
and went to Montgomery Blair High School.
Eric Hutchinson: Yes, I did.
Not a ton of Blair people here
apparently but --
male #5: Yeah, cool.
Eric Hutchinson: Did you go to Blair?
male #5: Yeah.
Eric Hutchinson: Oh, great.
What year did you graduate?
male #5: 2003.
[chuckles]
Eric Hutchinson: Okay, cool.
male #5: Yeah I don't know if
you were in like cap back then.
Eric Hutchinson: I was in the cap
for a while yeah.
male #5: I was in the magnet.
Science magnet anyway.
So I was just wondering like
I don't really think of
there being that much of
like acoustic pop music scene
I don't know in Takoma Park,
Silver Spring area --
but like did you develop
much as a musician then
or is there a scene I wasn't aware of
or was it more when you got to college -- [laughter]
Eric Hutchinson: You were
never invited over to the -
yeah, no I--
there wasn't necessarily.
I didn't get involved with
hardly anything in high school
which is one of my big regrets.
I did almost nothing,
everything I did was on my own.
I worked on music or I was
actually a film major in college
so I made a lot of
short films stuff like that,
but I wouldn't say there
was a huge community no.
I mean mainly my family just sort of
played music for me when I was young
and I kinda just got into it and
then when I went to college
started getting more into it.
Yeah I'm not really sure exactly
where it came from
other than my parents bought one of
the first CD players that was available,
they paid like $500 for it
and all they had for a while
was the entire Beatles catalog,
like literally it was like the 13 CDs
and that was all we had.
So I remember there just being sort of
a high importance on music in the house.
[applause]
00:42:05.367,00:00:00.000